c'est arrivé dans la nuit de lundi à
deux reprises les sept astronautes de la
station spatiale internationale a dû se
réfugier dans leur vaisseau d'évacuation
d'urgence parce qu'un nuage de débris
métalliques passait à proximité
le coupable un tir de missile russe qui
a pulvérisé le vieux satellite qui se
trouvait à 60 km de la station hier les
américains étaient furieux
japonaise aujourd'hui le teint en a
rajouté deux bris actions posées risque
d'une activité in space pas
déontologique
parmi les 1500 débris provenant de
l'explosion du satellite certains
auraient pu croiser la route de la
station spatiale et mettre en jeu la vie
d'équipage qui comprend deux cosmonautes
russes
frappés par exemple vite
évacuée il faut rappeler que ce n'est
pas la première fois qu'une puissance
spatiale test missiles antisatellites
les américains les indiens et les
chinois l'ont également fait mais après
60 ans d'activités spéciales les débris
ce qu'ont déjà par centaines de milliers
et on craint de devoir cesser toute
forme d'activité en orbite ci par un
effet de cascade
leur nombre augmente encore plus la
problématique c'est que ça crée des
débris qui eux vont être dangereux non
pas pour les heures qui suivent mais
pour des années et même des décennies
ces débris l'eau vont rester en orbite
plusieurs systèmes de récupération des
débris sont encore à l'étape des tests
ou de la planche à dessin mais c'est une
solution temporaire selon les experts de
nouveau traité sur l'utilisation de
l'espace sont absolument nécessaire pour
réglementer ces activités hautement
stratégique de l'autre socialiste moscou
ya d'ailleurs fait allusion à sa
réplique à washington que la russie
accuse d' hypocrisie pour son refus
depuis des années de négocier un traité
destiné à prévenir une possible course
aux armements dans l'espace
ici normand grondin radio canada
montréal